hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his treatise
on human nature in book two part three
section three David Hume will bring up
this conception of calm passions which
sounds to us in the present very much
like an oxymoron but plays an important
role in his moral philosophy
particularly in his account of human
action and what makes our
decision-making processes actually work
or how the will is determined and Hume
has already argued by the point that he
brings this up that reason by itself
doesn't actually oppose passions so if
we're feeling a strong passion like fear
or desire or anger or hope or joy
sadness grief pick whatever you want
reason by itself cannot actually oppose
these so what then can well one thing
that can oppose a passion is another
passion and Hume is going to tell us
that not only do we have violent
passions the things that we typically
understand as our human emotions desires
drives but that we also have these what
he's calling calm passion
or as he'll to use other language that
he uses in this section desires or
tendencies he also talks about them as
actions of the mind as well and if we
think about what these are they're
coming from as he says the same faculty
as the other passions they're not coming
from the faculty that deals with truth
and falsity they're not coming from the
understanding or reason they are coming
from our faculty of effectivity or
however you want to label it and it
tells us that these these come in two
main ways
he says there's certain column desires
and tendencies which though they be real
passions produce little emotion in the
mind and are known more by their effects
than their immediate feeling or
sensation they're of two kinds either
here's the first kind certain instincts
originally implanted in our natures so
these are these are the things that you
can count on every single human being
having unless there's some sort of
deficiency of human nature within that
person and it gives us what we shouldn't
take to be an exhaustive list but it
gives us some great examples I said such
as benevolence this this desire to help
other people to do good to them he also
calls this sympathy at other places and
here's another example resentment that
is when we feel like we're being treated
in a way that we don't like we want to
retaliate or cause the other person some
pain or humiliation some lowering of
their status other examples of this he
says are the love of life this constant
desire to continue in existence and to
do the things that will actually augment
our existence and to ward off the things
that will will impede it and then he has
a very specific example kindness to
children this is something that he seems
to think is implanted within us and when
we might extend this not only to
children but even to you know animal
little children of animals you know like
hit ins and puppies or anything like
that that senses oh look how cute that
kitten is right humans say that's
actually a calm passion that we feel so
these are things that can oppose other
passions then he says there's another
class of comp ashens and it calls this
the general appetite to good and
aversion to evil considered merely as
such so considered without any
particular object but just considered in
general and this is something that you
know it plays a major role within human
moral psychology and his ethics but I
think also you can see playing a role in
many other people's moral philosophy as
well particularly this general appetite
it's a good and aversion to evil which
is the basis of for example natural law
theory right so humans saying that we
all have these unless there's been some
sort of damage to our human nature in
some way we all have these operative
within ourselves churning away going
without us feeling them as strong
emotions but they can sort of keep us on
track and they can oppose other passions
now he says that these are easily
confused with the determinations of
reason now why would that be why would
these calm passions coming from a
different source than rationality be
confused with rationality he says well
reason itself doesn't produce any
sensible emotion so it proceeds that
every action of the mind which operates
with the same calmness and tranquillity
is confounded with reason by all those
who judge of things from the first view
and appearance which would include not
only ordinary people but in his view
many other intellectuals and even moral
philosophers they are judging by the
lack of being moved
a violent way that that what the calm
passions are dictating is in fact the
voice of reason he also gives us another
explanation for this as well that
there's a similar sensation going on he
says that whenever any of these passions
are calm and caused no disorder in the
soul they're readily taken for
determinations of reason they're
supposed to proceed from the same
faculty with that which judges of truth
and falsehood their nature and
principles have been supposed the same
because their sensations are not
evidently different they feel the same
to us it's sort of a lack of feeling
however and so humans saying what's
really important here is that we've got
two different faculties in play now he
also tells us that we do have these
violent emotions though the things that
we typically think of as passions or
emotions
he says there's violence emotions of the
same kind which you have a likewise a
great influence on that faculty so he
has in this example when I receive any
injury from another I often feel a
violent passion of resentment which
makes me desire his evil and punishment
independent of all considerations of
pleasure and advantage to myself when I
am immediately threatened with any
grievous ill my fears apprehensions and
aversions rise to a great height and
produce a sensible emotion so this leads
us to be able to oppose those passions
to things like these instincts
originally planted like the desire for
self-preservation or the desire not to
harm you know the innocence the anger or
fear could drive us to ignore that and
whom tells us something really
interesting here about how we ought to
judge human beings morally ethically so
when there's a conflict between these
calm passions that are always operative
within us to some degree and more
immediate violent passions which could
lead us to do other things and
when these are actually in conflict with
each other what decides what determines
us what settles the account and has us
go one way or the other
Hume tells us that there's two main
things that we can look at one is the
general character of the person the
other is the present disposition of the
person so the state that the person is
in at the time perhaps they're stressed
out perhaps they're laboring under some
misapprehensions that could be part of
their general they're there a particular
present disposition but we can also
think about the general character of a
person some people are prone to anger
other people are prone to allowing fear
to drive them to do things that their
other drives or instincts or whatever
you want to call them would say no no
this is not a good idea and to do things
that other people don't seem to fall
into and we can say the same thing about
desires for different pleasures or
aversions grief can make people do all
sorts of things you know the desire to
take care of one's children great
motivator to doing the wrong thing I'm
like you know counts of many people we
could think of the corruption scandal
recently but just think about how you
have to tell parents at sporting events
not to yell at the referees when their
team is losing or at the coach for not
putting their kid in you know those are
examples where disposition would play an
important role but it could also be you
know the present or the disposition or
the general character of that person
would be deciding it so he says what we
call strength of mind implies the
prevalence of the calm passions above
the violence
a person who has presence of mind
typically will follow their calm
passions instead of following the
violent emotions that they're feeling
but he also sells says that we may
easily observe there's no person so
constantly
possessed of this virtue has never on
any occasion to yield to the
solicitations of passion and desire and
so this allows us to understand how it
is that we often do these things that
are not just reasonable but are based in
our human nature without necessarily
having some sort of great effective
emotion at every single point and how it
is that we can have a conflict between
what appears to be reason and appears to
be desire but is really calm passion and
violent passion in conflict with each
other
mediated by general character and
present disposition of the person
you